so i am absolutely
the kind of person who would
take 15 minutes trying to decide
what ice cream flavor
it's called a paradox of choice
and it is an increasing problem
for a lot of people living in the modern
world
and it happens when neither of the
choices
are either good or bad and
you neither love or hate either of them
so your compass for making decision just
gets
all screwed up and when i look back at
that time well
actually i still do that it was like a
disease
i was plagued by the little decisions
that i had to make
and i didn't realize how much energy was
taking out of my life
until i read this article by
james clear on decision fatigue he talks
about this research by
the national academy of sciences where
they study
1100 judicial hearings over a 10-month
period so these were all
parole board judges who basically had to
decide
if the criminal had to stay in jail or
if they could be
released on parole and what they
realized is that
it wasn't actually the context or the
particulars of the crime that had the
biggest impact on their decisions
but it was actually the time of day so
at the beginning of the day
the percentage of a favorable ruling
would be up about
65 and near the end of the day it would
drop down to zero
and this happened all across the board
and so after reading this article
i decided to do a bit of an extreme
experiment and i basically decided i'm
gonna
stop making any small decisions
[Laughter]
so if i went to a restaurant i would
just ask the staff for recommendations
and if i got ice cream i would just tell
my friend to get me whatever she's
having
and then the second thing i started
doing is for any big decisions in my
life
i gave myself a time limit to make those
decisions
because i felt like yeah it's actually a
huge waste of my time
and i wasted my energy to keep thinking
about the same problem over and over
again
so i actually did this for six months i
ate whatever someone else
ordered for me for six months but what i
realized is that i
i actually felt a visible like a weight
lifted off of me and i just had more
energy to make
other decisions in my life so basically
willpower
is like it's like a muscle if you keep
using it throughout the day it's gonna
get tired and it's gonna fade away
throughout the day so here are some
slightly more practical ways
you can reduce decision fatigue and
increase
willpower so the first one take a couple
of minutes
the night before to make all the small
decisions
so plan out what you're gonna wear plan
out what you're gonna eat for breakfast
this way you're not wasting your
precious willpower on those
little decisions and number two do the
most important things
first you know studies have shown over
and over and over again that your mind
is more focused and clear in the morning
so you know whether it's like learning a
new language or writing a new book
try to do that right in the morning and
number three schedule your tasks
if you're let's say trying to lose
weight
schedule the workouts right in your
calendar if you
trust yourself to make that decision
after a long day of work you are
mistaken my friends
your willpower is going to run out and
it's gonna be harder
and harder for you to make those hard
decisions i
schedule my writing right in the morning
from 6 00 am to 7 30 am
i actually started doing this not long
ago and i
love it because i know that once i get
back from work
i'm tired all i'm gonna wanna do is just
chill on the couch and so yeah having
that right in my schedule it's a great
way to keep consistent
and then number four is eat
work out and recharge so
the study that i was talking about
before showed that
the judge's favorable rulings spiked up
right after they had their lunch breaks
you know obviously if you're eating
pizza
or junk food and you get into a food
coma after
that's not really gonna work out um so
try to eat healthy foods
and also sneaking in a little bit of
exercise during the day can also be a
really great way to recharge
for me i i bike to work
or i speed walk to work and
that actually helps me get really
energized for work in the morning
and if you want to try going the extreme
route that i did
and try cutting out all the small
decisions in your life
i would try it you'd be surprised at how
many of them
really doesn't make friends
you